thomas piketty 'he's capital in the 21st
century has been getting a lot of
attention lately because it's addressing
a an issue that matters a lot to a lot
of folks the issue of income inequality
and wealth inequality and my goal here
isn't to have a view on the book to say
the book is all right or it's all wrong
but to really use this book as a tool to
give you the the critical thinking tools
you need to make your own judgment the
one thing that is neat about the book is
that he makes all of the charts and
figures available on his website so all
of these screenshots that I got these
are from picady dot psee nsfr slash e n
slash capital 21 C 2 and I encourage you
to go there on your own and to browse
these charts because there's a lot of
interesting charts but as you do so
always look at them with it both an open
and a critical eye to see how what makes
sense or what might not make sense or
what questions start to emerge that you
would like to dig deeper on but let me
just start with this chart right over
here because this is this begins to lay
out what might be an issue so this is
wealth inequality in the United States
between 1810 and 2010 and the way that
they're measuring wealth inequality is
the share of top decile or percentile in
total wealth so here they're saying the
top 1% share of wealth that's this this
line right over here and then you have
the top decile the top 10% share in
wealth so this right over here this data
point let me do this in magenta this is
telling us that based on his data in
1810 the top 1% the wealthiest 1% had
roughly it looks like about 25% of the
wealth of the country and the top 10%
had about looks like it's almost maybe
almost 60 percent of the wealth of the
country and then we see how this is
trending and it was trending up as we go
through the 1800s all the way until the
beginning of the 20th century so this is
the 19th century right over here
beginning of the 20th century and in
particular we have this period in the
last few deck
the last two or three decades of the
19th century the 1800s that's often
known as the Gilded Age the Gilded Age
that's associated with fairly dramatic
wealth inequality gilded gilded age and
one of the the questions that this book
raises is are we entering into another
Gilded Age now if you just look at this
trend line here it's it's clear that the
wealth inequality isn't as severe as it
was in the I guess you could say formal
Gilded Age but it's a question of where
is this going and is this something that
people should be concerned about so the
question is is this trend line going to
do what it did in the last few decades
of the 19th century and do something
like this essentially maybe bringing at
least this chart more in line with what
happened during the first Gilded Age or
is it going to do something like this or
is it going to do something like that
and even if it does do something like
this are we going to have the same
realities that we had in the first gilt
Gilded Age where it's maybe
disproportionate power sociated with
that wealth or whatever else so these
are all the types of questions that we
should be thinking about what type of a
reality are we going into what is the
data that is that is making us believe
one or the other and what are the policy
decisions on things like innovation or
taxation or education that might lead us
one way or another and so I will dig
deeper into all of those ideas over the
cirrie or the the next few videos in
this tutorial